foreign
Africa is perhaps the continent that
needs least convincing about the clean
energy opportunity for health
livelihoods and economy
as the fastest growing yet least
electrified continent on the globe most
in need of Power Systems that can help
fortify against the onslaught of climate
shocks and with the with both abundant
fossil and renewable energy resources to
build them
Africa's energy Transitions and how to
dissuade the use of fossil fuels have
become an intense international debate
but what the debates often miss is that
Africa is not a single story
as an energy systems modeler I can tell
you that though the Baseline is low
where they do have power many
sub-Saharan African countries already
rely on low carbon resources
Kenya where I live generates 90 percent
of its power from Renewables like
geothermal and hydropower
even in West Africa where renewable
shares tend to be lower countries like
Ghana generate over a third of their
power from renewable energy resources
and countries like Namibia are at the
Forefront of innovation on clean fuels
like green hydrogen
couple all of that with housing one of
the world's largest carbon sinks the
Congo Basin and sub-Saharan Africa is
consistently recognized as pulling more
than its fair share of the global
decarbonization effort
so unlike the Deep emissions reductions
an urgent pivot away from fossil fuels
we need to see from heavy emitters
sub-Saharan African energy transitions a
more question of how to quickly ramp up
generation and distribution capacities
in ways that are affordable accessible
resilient
while staying the course of climate
compatibility
so if the need is urgent and if the
resources are Bountiful then why are we
still so far away from this clean energy
future for Africa
I've led the design and deployment of
energy projects here myself
and I found and what I've learned is
that though the world loves to remind
Africa about its vast clean energy
potential
the financial flows to deliver that
potential remain troublingly scarce
projects and businesses incur a number
of hidden compounding costs and premiums
like the risk perception premium
or the paying back your US Dollar Loan
in a constantly depreciating local
currency premium
or the expected to deliver
conventionally High rates of return
while raising your revenues from
customers that earn less than a dollar a
day premium
so international finance markets are not
advertised and financial flows here
remain a trickle despite a pipeline of
ready projects
effectively this prioritizes risks to
Capital
over risk to human life
in fact though 17 percent of the global
population and almost 90 percent of
those still without access to Basic
Energy today Africa accounts for Amer
two percent of global clean energy
Finance
these realities of local Enterprise
rarely make it into the models or the
debates
leaving us with a skewed perception of
what transition really takes or why
progress might seem so slow
from this perspective we can see a key
missing ingredient
International cooperation to deliver the
finance flows that Africa sorely needs
because there's so much potential
waiting right at the cusp if local
Enterprise had access to long-term
low-cost financing like their
counterparts in other regions of the
world can simply take for granted
then Africa's Clean Energy Future would
build itself
we know this because African communities
by their actions show us the kinds of
Futures that they want
as our cushioned conferences wax on year
after year
my friend Jeffrey runs a Solar Company
that targets commercial and Industrial
customers
helping to kick-start what has become
the fastest growing wave of solar across
the continent
and also demonstrating that African
businesses see value in being powered by
Renewables
my neighborhood buddy Samir runs a solar
irrigation company
it's estimated that about 95 percent of
farmers in Africa still rely entirely on
increasingly erratic rains so this is a
game changer for food security
my former student Phoebe she Now Designs
fuel efficient cook stoves that reach
into thousands of homes from Zambia to
Mozambique providing sustainable
alternatives to what is actually the
largest energy use on the continent
household cooking
and at the World Resources Institute we
support dozens of young Rwandan Ugandan
and Kenyan Electric Mobility startups
that are revolutionizing the face of
transit in East Africa
these are real people real stories real
families representing a real wave of
local Enterprise
successfully serving communities across
an entire spectrum of energy needs
these are real salaries real rents real
mortgages real savings being put on the
line every day
is that not the utmost confidence in
Africa's clean energy business potential
imagine how fast we could go and how far
we could move if they had a Level
Playing Field instead of yet more
obstacles to climb
and if they can be invested then what
excuse remains for those with the means
and the responsibility
Africa is speaking
but it's not one story it's not even 54
stories it's the stories of thousands of
communities mobilizing the Futures they
want and inviting the world's
partnership in it
partnership
not charity not a victim song
but fairness and cooperation
ambitious time-bound commitments to
deliver long-term low-cost financing at
scale from countries Banks and
development Finance institutions
two
increased concessional financing not
reclassified financing
that doesn't just Target the easily
profitable projects but that is
leveraged to drive Global Capital to
least electrified communities
and three
programs that expand the access to that
finance and initiatives that bolster
local Supply chains generating value
revenues employment and skills at home
these are the solutions that the
International Community must make an
urgent priority even as African
countries do their own homework to
improve the local business environment
and this
delivering accessible clean energy
financing at scale will be a far more
productive show of partnership and Trust
than debating what countries should do
with their available resources
climate Justice is heavy emitters
cooperating to realize Clean Energy
Futures for those countries that have
been denied locked out of their fair
share of a global carbon budget
so today let's cut past the talk and
focus on unleashing the Avalanche of a
clean energy future that Africa is ready
to deliver
thank you
[Applause]